non ça me dérange pas du tout je suis je
suis complètement cours je pense que
c'est une très bonne idée ça va nous
permettre de nous sentir déjà plus en
sécurité surtout que là on voit déjà que
qu'elle est qui et les restaurants les
terrasses bomba semblant d donc du coup
ça ça nous permettrait beaucoup de
soucis au respect ce de sécurité
vis-à-vis de la situation parce qu'on
sait qu'il ya toujours des infections et
a toujours belle et hugo vide est
toujours là quoi non pas spécialement
ça me dérange pas je trouve que pour
revenir à la vie normale ça va être un
petit peu nécessaire donc moi ça me
dérange pas bah il ya déjà plein de
vaccins qui sont obligatoires en vrai
donc si jusque là on n'en parle plus
parce que c'est médiatisé que ça a
touché tout le monde sur la terre
entière quoi donc sur le principe au
final non je ne dors pas je pense que ça
peut être une bonne idée faut voir s'ils
commencent avant mais ça remplace sur
plusieurs essais après peut-être voir
mais pas pas de décision de suite que ça
va j'ai pas un avis prononcé de suite
pourquoi pas tout dépend après sur le
contrôle de dire on sait comment ça fait
/
vraiment ça va dépendre de la mise en
place en fait voilà mais non en soit ça
me dérangera qui me dérange non quand on
me dit comme ça après après quand enfin
parce qu'on fait on est pris dans la
vague de vouloir ressortir et c'est là
donc c'est vrai qu'on est vite pris dans
le vaccin le passé militaire extérieure
après c'est vrai que ça laisse quand
même à réfléchir au niveau des
restrictions des libertés etc
donc voilà bon j'ai pas de réponse
tellement mieux plus à apporter mais en
tout cas moi ça me fait quand même un
peu réfléchir mais j'ai l'impression
d'être prise dans la vague du truc et du
coup ne pas avoir vraiment de temps et
l'occasion de vraiment y réfléchir en
fait c'est un peu paradoxal parce que on
se pose quand même la question de la
nécessité de faire cela et en même temps
en même temps c'est à mettre en question
quand même enfin voila je suis pas je
vais vers là quand même vers le passé ni
terre le vaccin terrain mais j'ai un peu
de recul quand même j'essaye d'avoir un
peu de recul et ne pose est quand même
en quelques questions
bah il ya un certain flou parce que moi
par exemple j'ai eu le qu'ovide est
effectivement le passé ni terre il ya un
petit fou parce qu'on sait pas comment
finalement je vais la voir parce que
j'ai pas le droit de faire le vaccin
je crois que ces trois mois ou six mois
et du coup je sais pas comment je vais
la voir parce que je dois faire le test
pcr mais enfin c'est flou il n'y a pas
assez d'information là dessus je trouve
enfin pour les vacciner c'est clair mais
pour les autres c'est pas encore assez
clair pour moi je pense que c'est une
bonne idée
au regard de la situation il faut toutes
ces voix si une limite il me semble demi
mille personnes non je pense que c'est
une mesure qui est responsable
simplement parce que il ya de plus en
plus d'entrain de contamination en fait
et sa vie justement endiguer le
développement du coc vide qui nous a
déjà frais car ralenti en fait notre vie
pendant un an
donc non je pense que c'est une très
bonne mesure aux confrères en fait moi
j'ai déjà l'application tous sentis
coded donc par cervelas j'ai déjà je
suis vacciné aussi donc j'ai mon pass
bas depuis j'ai entre guillemets déjà le
pastel iter aux cayes aussi un qr code
qu'on donne avec le vaccin
donc moi y'a rien qui me gêne là dessus
après ce b du moment que c'est paco f1
coercitif et que ça en dit pas trop
notre nos libertés qui ont des réalités
biens saccagés quand même pendant un an
ça va voyez donc moi ça me ça ne me
dérange pas plus que ça
ben non moi ça me dérange parce que
comme j'ai déjà fait ma première dose de
vaccin que je compte aller au bout je me
dis que ça peut permettre d'éviter que
ça se propage en fait est de pouvoir
rendre possibles les festivals et ces
choses là en fait